BRIEFING.
LET'S GO OUT TO SAN FRANCISCO
NOW ON THE PELOSI CASE.
>> I AM SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BROOK JENKINS.
AND I WANT TO START BY FIRST
SENDING OUR WELL-WISHES TO
MR. PELOSI ONCE AGAIN.
WE ARE TRULY PRAYING FOR A
SPEEDY RECOVERY ON HIS PART.
I WANT TO ALSO START BY THANKING
THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR IMMEDIATE
AND SWIFT INVESTIGATION OF THIS
CASE.
I AM HERE TODAY TO FORMALLY
ANNOUNCE CHARGES AGAINST
MR. DAVID DEPAPE IN CONNECTION
WITH WITH THE VIOLENT ATTACK ON
MR. PELOSI.
THE CHARGES THAT WE ARE FILING
TODAY INCLUDE ATTEMPTED MURDER,
RESIDENTIAL BURGLARY.
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON,
ELDER ABUSE, FALSE IMPRISONMENT
OF AN ELDER AS WELL AS THREATS
TO A PUBLIC OFFICIAL AND THEIR
FAMILIES THESE CHARGES ARE BASED
ON THE FOLLOWING FACTS.
AFFIDAVIT FILED TODAY AS WELL AS
IN THE MOTION TO DETAIN
MR. DEPAPE THAT WE FILE
TOMORROW.
MR. DEPAPE SPECIFICALLY TARGETED
THE PELOSI HOME TO CONFRONT
SPEAKER PELOSI.
HE FORCED HIS WAY INTO THE HOME
THROUGH A REAR GLASS DOOR BY
BREAKING THAT GLASS.
THE DEFENDANT MADE HIS WAY
UPSTAIRS TO THE SECOND FLOOR OF
THE HOME.
LOCATING MR. PELOSI IN HIS BED
SLEEPING.
HE WOKE HIM UP CONFRONTING HIM
ABOUT THE WHEREABOUTS OF SPEAKER
PELOSI.
MR. PELOSI, WHO WAS SLEEPING WAS
WEARING A LOOSE FITTING PAJAMA
SHIRT AND BOXER SHORTS HE WAS
FORCED TO GET OUT OF BED AND
SOMETIME IN THAT ENCOUNTER
MR. PELOSI ATTEMPTED TO ACCESS
THE ELEVATOR IN THE HOME WHICH
HAS A PHONE.
THE DEFENDANT THEN BLOCKED
MR. PELOSI'S ACCESS TO THAT
ELEVATOR.
IT WAS AT SOME POINT AFTER THAT
MR. PELOSI ASKED TO GO TO THE
BATHROOM, WHICH IS WHERE HE WAS
ABLE TO CALL 911 FROM HIS CELL
PHONE THE DEFENDANT REALIZING
THAT MR. PELOSI CALLED 911.
TOOK MR. PELOSI DOWNSTAIRS NEAR
THE FRONT DOOR OF THE RESIDENCE.
TWO POLICE OFFICERS ARRIVED AT
THE FRONT DOOR TWO MINUTES AFTER
THAT 911 CALL.
WHEN THAT DOOR WAS OPENED, THE
DEFENDANT WAS HOLDING HIS
HAMMER, WHICH MR. PELOSI
APPEARED TO BE ATTEMPTING TO
CONTROL BY HOLDING A PORTION OF
THAT HAMMER.
THE DEFENDANT THEN PULLED THE
HAMMER AWAY FROM MR. PELOSI AND
VIOLENTLY STRUCK HIM IN THE TOP
OF HIS HEAD.
THE POLICE THEN IMMEDIATELY
APPREHENDED THE DEFENDANT.
WHAT WE ALSO HAVE LEARNED IS
THAT THE DEFENDANT BROUGHT TO
THE LOCATION OF THE PELOSI
RESIDENCE A SECOND HAMMER AS
WELL AS ZIP TIES, ROPE, AND A
ROLL OF TAPE.
WHAT IS CLEAR BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE THAT WE HAVE THUS FAR
IS THAT THIS HOUSE AND THE
SPEAKER HERSELF WERE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETS OF THE
DEFENDANT.
AS FOR NEXT STEPS, THE DEFENDANT
IS EXPECTED TO BE ARRAIGNED
TOMORROW AFTERNOON.
MY OFFICE WILL BE FILING A
MOTION TO DETAIN HIM WITHOUT
BAIL AMEND THAT IS BASED ON WHAT
IS OBVIOUS AND SEVERE PUBLIC
SAFETY RISK THAT THE DEFENDANT
POSES TO SAN FRANCISCO AS WELL
AS THE OUTER COMMUNITY.
VIOLENCE HAS NO PLACE IN THIS
CITY.
WE WILL WORK VIGOROUSLY TO HOLD
THE DEFENDANT ACCOUNTABLE.
ONE LAST THING THAT I WANT TO
SAY TODAY IS THAT AS LEADERS AND
AS CITIZENS IT IS INCUMBENT UPON
US ALL TO WATCH THE WORDS THAT
WE SAY AND TO TURN DOWN THE
VOLUME OF OUR POLITICAL
RHETORIC.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO ALL ENGAGE
IN PASSIONATE POLITICAL
DISCOURSE BUY STILL REMAIN
RESPECTFUL OF ONE ANOTHER.
VIOLEN